miss dominique alors aujourd'hui vous
avez perdu commune kg
70 70 kg
plus de deux cent mille exemplaires
vendus premier single certifié dehors
aussi et puis en 2004 le groupe prend
fin parce que tout simplement matt
pokora décide de partir pour une
carrière solo lionel essaie de faire
aussi un petit peu là la même chose est
en réalité à ce moment là on va dire la
vérité c'est s'en va et c'est un peu la
descente aux enfers lionel ouais tu
t'aperçois que ton téléphone sonne plus
que tu essaie d'appeler t charger de
prod chez m6 qui la veille te disais mon
chouchou tout va bien se passer puis du
jour au lendemain y'a plus rien quant à
lui rapporter combien de faire des
linkup quand tout et pour tout j'ai pris
soixante dix mille euros et est ce que
j'avais à dire aussi ces voix là parce
que je les ai vus faire quand on reçoit
matt pokora qui est assis ici parce
qu'il a fait une tournée de tous les
zéniths et que tu es chauffeur de salle
pour applaudir et que tu applaudis et
aux copains si chat d'horribles caisse
course en ce moment là
une fois contraire parce que moi je sui
fra ger je tombe je t'en prie un
terreau pour ton ami mais
chercher
ses complexes parce que ça te renvoie en
fait tu puisses et indépendante à
volonté tut tut tut barre pour
tu te bats pour rester humble en fait
dire non c'est cool c'est normal la
viéle et dur il faut rester faut rester
fort était content pour lui et tu dis
est ce que cette poussière des toiles
qu'il a permis d'aller là où il est
pourrait pas d'avoir un petit peu pour
toi ça pour être pas retomber un petit
peu pour toi mais aujourd'hui je suis
heureux je suis heureux de faire le
métier que je suis je suis content
d'être avec vous sur cette laptop
aux millions tu m'as dit geler
totalement perdu comment tu as perdu ce
million c'est surtout les faux amis
d'accord voilà j'avais il ya une époque
où j'avais un groupe d'amis autour de
moi que je pensais mes amis donc j'ai
j'ai voulu leur faire plaisir je pensais
vraiment que cette offre est qu un jour
une voiture pas du tout je leur payer
les soirées on prenait le taxi je
pouvais pas leur payer des vacances
voilà et mais ces voix là
on sait on pense se faire plaisir on
pense qu'on a le temps et puis bah je
l'avais aussi wallons pensent qu' il va
y avoir d'autres galas d'autres machins
on a fait les zénith quand on gagne un
million d'euros allait chanter pour 250
ou 300 euros pendant deux heures dans un
mariage et la chance comment comment on
le vit quand même
je suis chanteuse oui je suis pas
chanteuse de zenit non un chanteur c'est
part réservée au zénith ce n'est pas
réservé aux grandes salles non
six disques d'or et vangelis six cent
mille exemplaires vendus très heureux de
vous revoir parce que c'est que votre
métier aujourd'hui justement si vous
êtes toujours fait des concerts plus que
jamais chanteuse puisque j'ai profité
des oeufs des deux années de provident
pour créer mon nouvel album we est
également on va dire que je suis
ambassadrice de la défense animale
d'accord grâce à l'association défense
de l'animal or ça c'est une très belle
pause mais moi ce que je veux savoir
c'est est ce que vous faites pas de quoi
vous vivez aujourd'hui vous faites des
concerts bien heureusement alors oui
mais vingt ans parce que j'ai démarré à
20 ans chaque été je fais à peu près 40
concerts après quarante concerts on a
fait un documentaire sur vous et vous
dites que vous faites à peu près où et
50 concerts par an et globalement ces
2000 euros le concert dont vous gagnez à
peu près cent mille euros par an puisque
vous dites annoncé un petit peu se
baptiser un c'est vous qui l'avez dire
cent mille euros par nom n'est pas mon
avis mon
oui c'est moi comme témoin pour moi mais
je suis à l'aise je suis heureuse
aujourd'hui vous voulez plus qu'on vous
appelle eve angeli c'est ça si possible
il a dit beaucoup mais je sais pas qui
vous êtes
merci c'est tout non mais tu sais les
gens exploités je vais lire ses marques
et maintenant des liens nous avons levé
lors j'ai dit tout simplement parce que
c'était quand même beaucoup associé à
une image pas toujours flatteuses vavoua
laquelle j'ai contribué je le reconnais
et voilà j'avais tout simplement envie
de laisser un petit peu derrière le
superflu et garder l'essentiel est alors
justement vous dites vous dites dans des
interviews qu'on a fait de vous vous
avez fait des mauvais choix parce qu'à
l'époque vous vouliez absolument
absolument habituellement exister
regardez il dans un tourbillon
médiatique f se perd
acceptant de se caricaturer à l'extrême
je sortais d'une émission de télé
réalité et à cette époque là mon propre
proposer plein de projets diverses et
variées c'était pas forcément toujours
bien conseillé malheureusement
ajoutez à ça le fait que tu as peur de
disparaître du jour en main vis tu te
dis si je dis non à ça peut-être que
demain on verra plus donc ça puisse le
fait que j'étais mal conseillés pour
durer dans le temps je prenais tout ce
qu'on me proposait dans l'instant t et
je n'avais pas de vision à long terme
j'étais un petit peu instrumentaliser à
cette époque
je m'appelle être qu'on parle d'abord de
vous miss dominique alors aujourd'hui
vous avez perdu commune kg
70 70 kg
quand vous étiez dans nouvelle star eh
bien vous m'avez dit j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour les stores foulem mais
faire gagner une fille kate est grosse
et noir c'était juste pas envisageable
c'est vrai ou pas
c'est à dire que je pense qu'ils aillent
ya des clichés c'est vrai mais c'est je
me suis dit c'est à toi de convaincre ah
ouais c'est à toi de séduire et c'est à
toi de faire ensemble que malgré tous
ces clichés mais ça toi te faire
apprécier oui mais vous me disiez lui il
était beau il y avait le petit côté un
peu cliché parisien vous me disiez quand
on chantait ensemble un duo comme par
hasard souvent à la caméra était plus
sur lui ou monter un fonds monté le son
de savoure mais c'est la vôtre c'est
vrai ou pas c'est sûr voilà aussi
[Musique]
bison n'est qu'une question mais
normalement humainement moitié mais
comment tu t'es retrouvé dans une
mission de chansons pour le peux je
pense que le public a accroché parce que
mais ont toujours voté pour moi donc
tant souhaité et peut-être le fait que
je ne prenne pas au sérieux et que je
fasse le corps donc comment tu te
retrouvais date à postuler non j'ai pas
poursuivi on est venu me chercher
j'étais sur une plage moi j'étais
pompier en plage du côté de
saint-jean-de-luz biarritz que tu
connais bien oui on est venu me chercher
en disant voilà ce que tu vas faire un
jeu où il faut chanter à la télé donc
j'ai cru à une blague au départ et puis
de cette blague et b c'est devenu une
énorme blague et était le beau gosse
donc y chocs bam la plus belle jennifer
s'est bien passé le janitor très bien
passé vous voyez encore je suis pas du
tout non pas du tout et je demande juste
ou non plus on a vécu un truc sympa
c'était très bien et fait le choix de
carrière vous êtes vous l'été dernier
pour nos shows ma tête j'ai vu très vite
way sur l'enregistrer ça s'est bien
passé même temps bon on l'a vu juste le
temps d'enregistrement donc on n'a pas
eu trop le temps beaucoup de boulot quoi
donc d'accord on l'a vu au vite fait
brièvement voilà mais c'était très bien
et fait une belle carrière est réussi et
tant mieux pour elle et elle le mérite
et forcément on se souvient de toi parce
qu'un jour tu peux tu es plus en plus
tôt tu décides de partir voilà qui à
londres tu as dû te tuer une anecdote la
droite qu'une anecdote je suis dans le
bureau de la directrice alexia laroche
joubert qui me dit jean pascal qu'est ce
qui se passe j'en ai marre je me cache
données veulent que ce jeu je m'en vais
mon épouse ok il faut que tu te reposes
tu vas partir quelques jours te mettre
au vert argy ok je vais chez moi elle me
dit non par tous sauf si l'anc en france
et moi nb si le jeu suit on peut londres
tu sais petit mec du sud est peut-être
ça fait voyager au lieu de dire cuba un
brésil et je suis parti c'est très joli
lob oui il a plus de quatre jours comme
ça qu'on verra sur les images mais j'en
garde un bon souvenir